So speaking of reformed [__] into
Housewives
um you know Logan Paul actually finally
spoke on Dylan danis's array of tweets
array so you guys if you haven't been
keeping up with the story Dylan Dennis
and Logan Paul have a fight in about I
think two weeks um and in preparation
for this fight Dylan has been tweeting
pictures of Logan's future wife his
fiancee pretty much every guy in
Hollywood she dated Leonardo DiCaprio
um a couple other A-list celebrities
there's pictures of her with LeBron
um and Logan Paul has finally
responded to this so why don't we pull
up the clip of him on flagrant the way
you got married yeah
I was dogging on you what I was talking
on you no to you to you yeah I don't
know if you remember this I was like
Andrew yo best of luck with that married
life yeah [__] dweeb yeah and you're
like you know if you find the right
woman it doesn't seem so bad and I
remember thinking this guy doesn't know
anything yeah Andrew is right I was
[__] right yeah I was right Dennis
entered the chat
is it has it has it been stressful at
all
oh there's a better question did you see
any Meme and you laughed a little and
then you're like wait a minute I can't
laugh
I can laugh
okay I can laugh
dude that one yeah which one some of
them are really funny can I can I guess
the one which one the turkey one is the
funniest yeah
I'm good at Twitter it is it is yeah
it's impressive no it's top tier trolley
yeah which is which is why I chose him
as an opponent you know but you didn't
know it was gonna go this hard no no no
no no no I had no idea
um but I mean we got people interested
right at the end of the day it's all
fight promo is there a little bit of
jealousy from from Tommy and KSI I don't
I don't John was jealous John was
[__] he was Furious he started
kicking tables yeah which was awesome I
mean it was like something out of Shrek
bro he's Game of Thrones
are the best family
[Laughter]
all right yeah John Fury is a legend of
the whole press conference was crazy I
you know Dylan hates me I don't give a
[__] about him I think he's an excellent
troll I think he's I think he's very
parasitic which is why I'm honored that
I get to be the one to like take him out
and embarrass him that's why I took the
fight I was like okay I know this guy's
gonna promote the [__] out of it people
are going to be interested because if he
showed goes up I get to be the one and
that that excites me and you have no
question what will happen if he shows up
nah I don't in fact can I get a drink
yes you can have a drink my boy
typically not but it's still a Danish
you know you're in New York bro yeah you
might get the Gap pulled up on you again
bro yeah he said he said that he's
he said that last time I was here you
said it what you said that when you were
on the Pod you were like yo Mike got the
got the pistola pulled on yeah but then
he started telling people that I had to
like check in when I came to New York so
what's up after this I'm gonna wait
outside for an hour I'm gonna give him
my address I'll see if he pulls up well
don't give him ours yeah
yeah listen let me think if I like this
or not let me just think if I like this
or not I don't I hmm he's not gonna come
up here beat up Schultz by default like
I'm not worried about getting beat up
I'm more worried about a shooting
happening you know
I feel like the gun consequences in New
York are pretty serious they are
producing yeah it's fairly severeign
[Music]
[Laughter]
why let me ask you something why would
there be stress between us
Andrew come here
I had to make sure the legs are also
getting worked out man it's trying to be
serious
don't do that okay so no stress between
you guys
[Laughter]
Milton he asked me if I'm transsexual
yeah
get him some tequila okay no for real so
no stress at all I'll tell you why
uh me and Nina
are so [__] open with each other I
knew she had long-term relationships her
whole life I knew some of them were very
public yeah she's been famous for
her entire adult life you know like 11
years she's been Paparazzi so none of
this surprised me and I know what kind
of person she is she knows what kind of
person I am and so like
dog you gotta understand at one point I
was the most hated person on the planet
like I've heard it all I've seen it all
I'm so numb to it I know who I am I know
who my girl is I know we love each other
some [__] internet troll posing as a
fighter is not gonna get me number one
none of us had ever heard of her before
this so I don't I don't think she was
that famous
Logan if you're watching this I doubt it
but you never know uh Logan if you're
watching this I really hope it works out
I really do I genuinely I wish you guys
the best I just don't see men that put
women on pedestals have good outcomes
typically
I really I just don't see it and I don't
see women
um being able to go from A-list
celebrities down
no offense I know you're a YouTuber
right so no no offense but
um
and I think that I keep seeing you put
her on a pedestal and I keep hearing you
say like I'm so lucky I get to be with
her
um and I think the mindset should be
more that she's lucky to be with you
because
um in all honesty her odds being like 32
and dating all these men in in Hollywood
really were not great
um in terms of locking down a guy that
she could stay with long term now
could it work out yeah possibly
um she just kind of gives me gold digger
Vibes
um being that she's chased after rich
and famous men
for a decade 75 guys you know is
a lot so again I really hope it uh works
out
um on top of that all the top comments
on this video is and you're not going
into the scam is unacceptable Joe Rogan
would have brought it up friend or not
so you know I now flagrant really is
getting a lot of pushback for not
talking about Logan
um scamming his fans um he he had a
cryptocurrency that came out that was
like a massive fail and a lot of people
lost money so because the I I do see
this from a podcast point of view
because sometimes it's like you only get
interviews if you have approved talking
points and you are trying to work with
people
um but at the same time I do think as a
journalist you have to do your due due
diligence
um so let me know in the comments if you
think he should have brought that up in
the interview so Dylan Dana says at that
point I might just need to release these
images on a human level to save Logan
from her if you guys know how nasty this
chick really is it's actually insane but
if I do the fight will be called off and
I'll be sued it's a hard choice
I just want to know what what is this
image that he's talking about
Dylan and the homies on a mission to
save Logan
oh gosh
you can see him he's still waiting
yeah I think it'll be interesting to see
what the Tweet is it'll be it'll be
interesting you know I really I I wish
them nothing but the best but I do not
see this working out I see a lot of red
flags but this is the problem when
people get this idea of like the one
it's we can kind of see in front of our
eyes how detrimental that is for both of
the men we've talked about today
actually all of the men for Tyrese
Gibson Steve Harvey Logan Paul they get
this idea of the one and when they think
they found her she can do no wrong and
women hate men that do not check them we
hate them